it's my last day at overview farms and
i i don't know where the time has gone
um
and i have to say i didn't expect to
like working with cows as much as i did
um i've been here a month now and i've
kind of made friends with a few of them
um they've all got their own
personalities so i wanted to introduce
a couple of my favorites to you this is
granny
she's my absolute favorite and poor
she can't walk very well she's getting
old she's got stuff in her feet
we've put some blocks on her to try and
help her walk but it's it's a chore for
her getting around
i come around in the morning and i get
her out of her stall and she's always
the last one and she'll sort of
make her way slowly down towards the
milking parlor and she'll look behind
her
as if she's saying are you sure are you
sure i have to go down there and say yes
and she will she'll eventually make it
down and she'll eventually make it back
and i just
i guess i just admire her persistence
but yeah i've got a soft spot for granny
and this is annabelle and annabelle
has got to be the most stubborn cow on
the farm
she was made a pet by the daughter of
the heifer razor when she was off farm
and so she doesn't think she has to
listen
and so when i come and get her up in the
morning
she'll be sitting in her stall and i'll
come along and
okay cows time to get up and she'll be
sitting in her stall and she'll look at
me
she said what are you gonna do about it
and so i'll i'll come and i'll have to
stand next to her and i'll give her a
pat
and you know let her know hey it's time
to go
and eventually she'll get up but in her
time
but despite all of her stubbornness
she's super curious and super
comfortable around people and
when i'm around she'll come and knows
and she'll just want to come and see
what i'm doing
and she's just really really friendly
and
kind of frustrating when you want to do
something
so we've got about 120 cows here
and as you can imagine 120 cows they eat
a lot of food
in fact they eat about two and a half
tons of food twice a day
and well two and a half tons is a lot of
feed
so we can't just sort of bring it out in
wheelbarrows
we need bigger machinery and it's
pretty simple this is a feed mixer if
you look inside there's two corkscrews
going around
turning and mixing the feed and then
robert toes the feed mixer down the
aisles of the barn
and the feed mixer just dispenses a line
of food right where the cows can get it
so this feed mixer is actually really
important because
the amount of milk that the cows produce
is tied to what they eat
and so a lot of thought goes into
getting the nutrition for the cows just
right
so i want to share well what do cows eat
so this bale here this is not hay um
and the plastic that it's wrapping is
actually really functional because when
it's wrapped up and made airtight
what starts out is hay inside ferments
and turns into what's called grass
silage which i think is a little bit
easier for the cows to digest
and to that you add a little bit of
milled corn
which adds calories and energy you'll
add
a little bit of soy meal or maybe some
canola
to add protein which helps keep the milk
production up
you'll add some minerals and some room
and bypass fat
which i think helps bulk them up
and then you'll top it all off with
another scoop of fermented hay
this is also grass silage but stored in
a silo
rather than in a veil and you mix all
that up
and that's what cows eat so this is my
last day at overview farms
and it's actually the last video i'm
going to make while i'm on a farm
i've been on the road for eight months
now and i've been filming the whole time
so i
really hope i have enough footage to
make a pretty decent documentary
but that means i'm going to take a
hiatus from these videos for a couple
weeks as i drive from nova scotia
all the way back to british columbia
where i'm going to edit the film
and then once i start editing the film
i'll start posting videos again
with some highlights of the footage or
maybe good interview clips
so i'll keep posting videos and you can
catch those videos by subscribing to the
youtube channel
you can find out more about the big
picture of the documentary by going to
the handset fetus.ca
you can follow me on facebook and
instagram and i'll see you in a couple
weeks when i
get back to british columbia